salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
vous le reconnaissez c'est l'ément biste
de chez Maison de la détection et
regardez ce qu'il viennent de nous
envoyer une attache pour accrocher deux
aimants ensemble vous pouvez attacher
tout type d'aimant là-dessus des 360°
c'est l'idéal bien sûr et aujourd'hui on
va faire le crash test donc regardez le
montage en fait les deux aentss quand
ils sont montés comme ça ils se
repoussent c'est pas facile à monter he
faut pas s'écraser mais regardez il se
repousse ce qui va permettre normalement
d'avoir deux fois plus d'objets alors
faut savoir un seul ément comme ça c'est
1400 kg de puissance les deux cumulés on
arrive à 2800 et en terme de poids là on
est sur un montage qui fait plus de 3 kg
donc on va voir ce qu'on arrive à faire
on fait un bon petit mouvement de
balancier dans tu es prêt et un get away
ok bon j'aicouvert la moitié du canal
c'est pas mal parce que là j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un objet mais je
suis même pas sûr
ouais si je dois avoir quelque chose
quand
même même pas ah c'est un
petit ouis une satature de voiture ouais
une ancienne ok bon c'est pas vide alors
bah écoute on relance tout de suite
vérifier comme c'est des ament neuf que
ça bouge pas que ça bouge pas alors sans
coincer les doigts entre on sait jamais
s'il y a une inversion d'épaule et que
que je perde des palalanges son d'épul
c'est pour la terre ça c'est un
phénomène climatique ça marche pas pour
les néod c'est super lourd je vais avoir
des bras mon pote c'est incroyable
ouis ça va ça
ça fait un big
plouou si vous voulez acheter ce genre
de choses elles sont disponibles dès
maintenant sur le site de maison de la
détection vous avez toujours le code
promo pêcheur de trésor qui s'affiche
ici et qui offre 5% sur toute la
boutique y compris sur les détecteurs de
métau si c'est votre truc mais pour les
objets qui viennent pas parfois je pense
que ça pe fa ça fait la di pense que il
y a vraiment un truc à
jouer j'ai un truc j'ai un
truc pour l'instant c'est validé
un chacun
ouais ça l'air cool en vrai ça a l'air
très cool c'est des essglaces il y a
peut-être une voiture là-dessous la
ceinture et les essuieglaces ouais ici
il y a que des morceaux de voiture dans
ce canal on le sait hein attends je
relance parce que en vrai pour l'instant
c'est ce que j'appelle un test très
concluant on va en faire un avec de
Barbarian trè remontée et trè objet je
pense donc très très validé pour
l'instant tout façon je vais continuer à
pêcher avec ça pendant toute la vidéo
après je prêterai à Quentin
maisee y a plein de ches je sais pas si
c'est les aim qui sont neuf et qui sont
super puissant mais il est
double d'habitude on a que les
simples sympa pu pour l'instant pas
d'accident tuas vu il s'och pas entre
non là c'est
bon
allez double Beast contre Barbarian on
va voir ce que ça donne ah
oui
d'accord j'ai quelque chose
ok c'est un morceau des ouais de solx ou
quoi
si on pas
long c'est morceau de mobyette ça je
crois toujours pensé à vérifier si sont
encore bien serré pas pêch parce que
c'est vrai que on est pas comme sur
lesents classiques il y a pas d'écrou
ici donc il y a seulement la le pas de
vis toujours vérifier votre attache si
pour le test on ne voulait pas fixer
définitivement nos é sinon vous pouvez
mettre de la colle exprès dans le pas de
vis elle est disponible aussi sur le
site de maison ça y
estin ok de l'os non
plastique je CIS que c'est un bout de
mâchoire avec les moules et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que qui dit doublément
dit aussi deux fois plus de poids donc
pour les coins où il y a beaucoup de vas
ça
racle d'accord voilà ça permet aussi
d'attraper des
moules des boulons qui viennent du pont
et je pense que mettre double Barb ce
serait de la gourmandise
oh du morceau de voiture encore ah il y
a un feu
ou un feu aquarium ok j'aime
bien
pas tout ce
Coutau C me j ça dans le
canal il est super bizarre Mme pourquoi
ça dépasse là le BO qui est cassé mais
c'est pas un truc de boucher ça c'est un
poignard avec bord comme ça
franchementesn en commentaire si vous
connaissez un peu les couteaux mais il
est il est effrayant tu là ah ouais bien
joué merci inst calme-toi c'est
rien ah ça y est ils ont dit le mot ça
va
ouais quelque chose là ouais un point
correct
ah
oh ah oui d'accord tu as quelque chose
de pas magnétique c'est une BRI non
c'est du béton
armé mais c'est magnétique ou pas même
pas m pas
is mais c'est ça il ben ça fait un effet
grapin en fait tu
vois ça va mon petit rasta tu te
promènes dans le fenouil
un petit coffre fort là serait pas mal
ouais tout le be nice it be so nice bon
déjà tu as fait un joli couteau ça
commence bien on est là depuis pas
longtemps
ouais nickel oh quelque chose c'est une
conserve non non uneence
ok cool bah ouais du coup c'est
intéressant B Traille peti enceinte je
pense qu'elle est morte mais les
boutonse dans la
vase et pour ceux qui se demandent si
jamais on trouve vraiment quelque chose
qui fait 2800 kg on a toujours un tre de
6 ton à porter de main et au pire on
arrivera toujours à décrocher les mens
en plongeant est-ce qu'on a quelque
chose et oui les doubl on tenu le
promesse on a une espèce de durite et
des morceaux de grillage alors oui
certains me diront que c'est pas fou
mais c'est déjà un bon début et c'est
par des petites choses qu'on finit par
trouver un vrai trésor on a fait un
short sur Xavier duup pont de ligonès et
je me suis fait grander parce que
j'avais dit il avait apparu plein de
gens qui m'ont dit ouais ça se dit pas
c'est été tu apparu nanani du coup j'ai
checké et ben avait apparu ça se dit
très bien et donc voilà je sais parler
le français moi aussi un petit peu
l'aut côté non
ouais y a rien on vient de passer de
l'autre côté du pont on va regarder ce
que ça donne ici il y a une petite route
abandonné là donc c'est toujours
possible de trouver des choses ah j'ai
peut-être quelque chose mais ça a pas
l'air très magnétique j'espère que c'est
pas du bois
ou là
regarde pas
mag
bon ça au moins dans l'eau
oua
oh ah ben là j'étais pas prêt de le
louper ça avec les deux aants morceau de
voiture ouais je pense ouais ah je pense
que moi aussi parirai sur ça là sur
l'objet qui galère là ça accroche pas
bien je fais que de le lâcher en vrai
toi tu le cherais
peut-être voouis là tu devrais le sentir
là ah j'avais raison et ouais tu vois ça
a choper un côté de chaque C ouais ça
c'est parfait un de chaque côté ou la
prise est parfaite effectivement avec un
ament normal à part si tu le chopes dans
l'angle là-bas oui tu peux quand même
mais c'est plus long ouais
ah
oh purée
ouais on a été un peu optimiste après
trois lancé ça y est je l'ai de nouveau
j'ai l'impression qu'il est encore plus
lourd que tout à l'heure
ouais je pense que c'est possible je le
tiens un peu mieux ok c'est bien le même
c'est pas un morceau de voiture hein non
et là truc non plus d'ailleurs c'est
pareil c'est le même truc ça c'est la
tole pour un toit P avec une petite
armature en plus ah mais quoi qu'il y a
de l'isolant aussi ah je sais pas je
sais pas si vous savez en
commentaire mais en vrai c'est lourd
ouais je sais is c'est pas de la tole de
merde en plus c'est rempli de caillou
elle est pas vieille to il y a les
découpes c'est encore brillant là ouais
peut-être la vase dedans quand même
ouais pour ça aussi que c'est lourd
ouais ouais c'est pour ça aussi
allez on continue franchement pour les
morceaux de carrosserie je pense que
c'est le top tuas encore quelque chose
là ou parce que d'habitude il viennent
jamais du premier coup ça vient bien un
bon petit poids encore allez
ou c'est un toit non c'est facile à
mettre dans l'utilitaire çaah ouais
ouais ils ont bien
travaillé ben en tout cas
mais attends mais ça revient de la même
que l'autre bout hein tu crois on dirait
c bien un bout de voiture ouais en tout
cas merci maison de la détection pour
pour les aimentss qui marchent bien si
vous voulez le vottre on l'a déjà dit
mais tout est en description on
conseille en général le terreur pour
débuter et ça avec deux terreur ça doit
être le top aussi on l'a fait avec de
Bistes mais on pe ça se fait avec de
terreors de Barba de hardcore un peu
avec
tout pendant que Quentin ne trouve rien
avec son simplément nous on a plein de
trucs avec le double tu m' tié ouais on
pas dans la même ligne ouais on dans la
même
ligne c'est pas si lourd eu qu'un sur de
ouais il est bizarre comme il réagit
c'est encore une forme de la carrosserie
mais ouais ça une forme bizarre regarde
oh là là bon c'est plat encore ça va ou
mais c'est grand ouais ntoi le bien
[Musique]
ok encore une fois le doubl validé
ouais B c'est terrible de trouver autant
de morceaux de voiture dans le canal
quand même les cas il faut les sortir
oui on veut trouver des c'est sûr on
préfère trouver du coffre fort et des
armes à feu mais ça fait toujours
plaisir et ce sera amené chez le
ferrailleur on va pouvoir le plier en
deux lui pour qu' rentre dans ouais
c'est recyclé au moins j'ai deux objets
en tout ah la carosserie elle retomberée
quoi
que perdu je
[Applaudissements]
croisd un morceau de carrosserie du
blanc encore du coup c'est la même sur
les c'est quoi mort là ou c'est ça que
je t'ai dit qu' a fait PL non non
d'accord si vous cherchez votre voiture
volée peut-être qu'elle est tout
simplement dans le canal ouais
dites-nous en commentaire si vous
reconnaissez votre
voiture ça réagit bizarrement par ah ok
d'accord ah il y en a d'autres morceaux
oh elle est hyper récente il est tout
neuf hein ouais c'est pas vieux hein
c'est un morceau d'utilitaire ça je
pense ouais on dirait le Peug expert il
est encore là-bas ouais c'est bon
vraiment
il est il est neuf celui-là
c'est r
qu'on et encore une fois pasans ah là
oua c'est clair par contre Le Fur il va
dire les gars c'est vous qui les coupé
dites la vérité il a même pas de vas à
l'intérieur il jeté dans la nuit
lui on va choper ah j'avais le pied
dessus en plus avec les 4 kg du truc là
ça m'a presque jeté dans
l'eauo regarde lui là regarde-le tu le
vois
essaie d'envoyer aussi mais c'est même
pas sur lui non tu non mais moi lui il
est pas aenté on dirait c'est bizarre il
vient pas du
tout ouais ouais
c'est il est neuf incroyable que la
personne qui a fait ça en commentaire se
dénonce ça doit être plein tout le
long à quel moment les mecs se disent on
va se garer là et on va jeter un
utilitaire découpé alors on peut dev
voir du pon c'est dingue bon d'accord il
doit faire ça à 5h du mat mais même quoi
c'est ça me paraît fou il y a tellement
de meilleurs endroit pour jeter mon bébé
qu'est-ce qu'il y a on a oublié les
croquettes
oh je pense que sans mentir j'ai deux
fois plus de chance de les avoir avec le
avec le setup comme
ça et regarde pourtant j'en ai eu qu'un
dessus ouais faut que tu
m'aides
tu sûr il y a la vitre
ouis j'ai
l'impression non
ok j'adore les portières c'est toujours
original à pêcher même si même si voilà
quoi dites-nous en commentaire les
connaisseurs portière arrière hein
ouais pas les voitur tu vois la poignée
elle est assez moderne
j'aurais dit un truc français ça oui
ok oh ça commence à faire du poids j'en
a enfin un ouais c'est pas fini hein
d'ure te réjouis pas trop vite oh bleu
c'est autre chose c'est detir là une
portière avec un jouet pour enfants là
les
oua
ça son plus
vieille oui c'est pas c'est pas jeté en
même temps que le truc blanc ça bien
joué
waouh peut-être une portière encore
ouais j'en peux plus entre les entre le
doublement de 4 kg à lancer et les
morceaux de voiture je suis cuit déjà
ouais c'était sûr
elle est rempli C de vas
la quantité de vas ou
ok qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ça a l'air
très
peuenté de
l'attraper c'est une
boîte il y a quelque chose à
[Applaudissements]
l'intérieur regarde il y a un truc
dedans je
pense
ça c'est un truc c'est dans les voitures
non
truc ok un peu
déçu ah non non
non
[Musique]
minusc la journée commence à décliner
mais on a encore des gros objets
donc
jouryen
chement ça tu on commence à le voir
regarde vas-y doucement qu'on le perde
pasil faut que j'envoie des
aimentss ah ouais tu veux faire un
assaut vas-y montre talents de
cowboy à l'arrière à l'arrière
non
OK
1 2
3 voilà là ça pas mal
ouais c'est ça au moins dans l'eau ou ça
reste une belle pêche ouais belle pêche
belle allée faire ailleurs on quand même
fait un joli couteau mais c'est vrai
quand tu objet originaux après voilà
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on remonte
des voitures de l'eau non plus hein
ouais ça nous fait du bien un peu ça
nous
[Musique]
entretient c'estm ah
plus manque un
peu ok 1
2 encore
un c'est bon
ouais